all right JJ oh just uh I say West Side
LA game laughter I would say and it's
Kenny guard yeah I still see stuff on TV
you know and you see movies and you
emulate the style the glamor the
attention and then it's time to protect
yourself you got an R to protect
yourself so looking at people come come
from you know older people older
influences I call them negative
influences and bad influences so you
start learning from
what to do we're not to do how to
protect yourself yeah
and you still got a vaulting accident
no that just it just been around when
you look out the door that's how you see
you know it was like let's say 7970 and
I said in the end of 79 it was going on
when no daddy's around it was probably
all dead or in jail you know that's the
plan yeah just a prison time over two
times I asked for basic violation and
hanging out now reporting did 16 months
they send me to prison and I lose all
right
it's back in the days then uh see I
stayed out five years I went back did
like ten I got a song battery and I did
that ten came on back yeah
never but never I never went back
I've been out for like 12 years
ain't nothing in there no I said why be
around a whole bunch of homeboys you
know I say I like honeys
you know I'm saying so yeah I'm cool and
I got along with a lot of people all
races did nummies Mexican white yeah
black I got along with everybody
yeah I call it like being multi culture
and I don't I don't pay to color line or
to race thing and I just like people
and you gotta like yourself first you
gotta care you know I was with my pops
they had the ups and downs
they wasn't perfect they was young so
you get involved with you better not be
one part of the gangs though so it was
like under the radar no why should it
oh I see smoke weed and it took them
down it's like I stopped having a drive
to go get the money the hustle have to
go get the job I try to draw I try it
use it as an excuse to not it took my
creativity away and it's an addiction
it took my incident diction right away
yeah sleep I uh yeah I I stopped using
that but I still had a temper I still
was mad and I used to get angry so I led
me to mess my take that case and uh
while I was there I found myself I
looked at myself eating that tight spot
a jail cell our casket you look at
yourself in a tight spot so I start
understanding myself I started knowing
myself and accepted myself and I guess I
started caring more about myself and
looking you know I'm not gonna let this
happen and I just just walk a look and
see those cars though behind trucks so
give me one of those give me a couple
ain't coming back so I got out I cut
grass I I did a whole bunch of work I uh
applications applications it's like we
do it on a computer you know you got to
do it on computer I see can I get an
application to fill out they don't do
that anymore they laugh at me it's
something we like we're not hiring just
slamming the door so I start getting
funny to me I kind of got it no I'm not
gonna get discouraged it starts by
selling a seat or you're gonna slam this
door slam it sit only see if they're
gonna I couldn't get no work so I said I
got one to a temporary job and I looked
at the check that week I said I make
this every day me and my father so uh we
uh I got me a truck he had a truck and
he had a lot of tools
he said [ __ ] up all the money you know
he said mister follow my knee so this is
all I got is these tools bar go away
he's all yours so we worked we moved we
painted we oversee all kind of like
apartment complex builders and stuff did
everything plumbing and he has so many
tools we just got work work work and I
kept me out
within dad like I didn't I learnt all
this out here you know I couldn't focus
in there there's too much stuff going on
no yeah riots and fights in there you
know it's just crazy so you got people
want to be rappers and you trying to
read the book in her he's over here
making noise beating on a desk so I
couldn't concentrate didn't you got to
watch her back all the time and I still
carry myself like that I won't drink I
won't smoke I won't smoke a joint I
won't smoke a cigarette it's like I'm
still in the yard I pay attention
yeah you got to be a aware of your
surroundings it's like you in the war
zone and I've seen a lot of like gore
you know I've seen streets prison seen
it you know ain't nice when I see the
environment that I'm around like right
here right now if I see something
starting to look funny gotta go I'm not
gonna stick stand around and you get
blowing up because you got a lot of
idiots out here I don't want to be
around me I'm gone no Sam and I gotta
look right here now 47 yeah little gray
hair now and uh it's wisdom I call it I
don't do the things I used to do you
know I don't I have done to prove no
yeah yeah I was very you know I was a
guest searcher for the attention deficit
disorder that we all had we're searching
for attention and you're gonna get that
attention list a lot of consequence is
going to come with that attention and
you start taking them steps no I throw
these things you know cuz you don't you
gonna get beat down anything could
happen and it's a survivalist it's a lot
of people got talent around here I look
at everybody like around here I look at
him like they're my family even if I
don't know him I still look at him as my
family because we're the ones from the
family that the family really like
Shawna's we're the black sheep of the
family we speak the same language we're
all got something in common we speak the
same language in this flock of the
sheep's right here we're the black
sheeps everybody else ain't got their
houses their kids they got their jobs
and their eating all this nasty food you
know sanding it all that stuff reason
why I'm so strong it's because I had it
so hard I had a real hard talk about
real hard how I still bite it to nothing
I don't ask somebody not for one
painting a quarter or a dollar all right
I never my father always taught me never
to action whitey from then Garth didn't
give us herself even when it came to him
he'll give me but his say I got to stop
giving you grown
get your own go get your own I got a
stop I Cologne you something you better
give that cuz I loaned him he'd get but
he said like I'd give it back to you
give me my back need anything but when
we long loan money to each other we
always give it right back
we never try to play games with each
other
beautiful values and you're walking
straight line how much in do you credit
your daddy yeah but I kind of didn't
listen because I did things behind his
back still but I always come up out of
it and then he acts why are you getting
in trouble so much or why are you doing
this why are you acting like that how
you dress up like Ted you know and then
it's like you hang with these dudes you
don't hang with you hanging I said I'm
not hanging with none of them
I'm hanging by myself give me some money
oh my you know I'm behind right now I
would say just tired being around a lot
of people a lot of people who lost a lot
people that got cheated a lot people
just had a chance but they could they
were so messed up on drugs they always
told me don't do this don't do that
don't snort this don't shoot this don't
drink this and those people they're all
dead now yeah I killed got a whole bunch
of time in prison for nectar you know
three strikes and when the law was in
effect and uh they never come home and
they're like legends it they taught me
they showed me how to work on cars
lowriders and stuff I was a little kid
give me a box of lowriders from 1977 he
gave me three boxes big box bigger than
these just full of all the riders and my
mother told me don't bring them home I
said but don't be worth something in the
future don't bring no more junk here and
that still herded me to this day because
I know those are the lost issues that no
one could never find he had all of them
and I really wanted that and I saw I
always wanted was support for my family
I need more support I need a support
period night to summer hit I'm living
here cuz they're taking it did a lot
taking kept me down say you're on a
crutch break the crutch yeah
cut throats yeah yeah I come from that
but I still walk like my grandfather you
know but not all the way but you know
have respect be courteous be kind to
people in general you know like elderly
people don't disrespect nobody don't
disrespect yourself
don't be sagging in your pants keep your
pants up I keep my pants because I'm
trying to get the job and yet I don't do
that yeah it's part of you it starts
with you within so those are some values
you know and uh I guess I'm supposed to
be kiss I'm still trying to I'll keep
the boy look just like you yeah supposed
to be my son must be my daughter you
know sure I got to try to look him up
I'm trying to do the DNA testing right
now I'm still waiting yeah unless I did
something wrong I got a call I'm still
waiting on him to call me yeah the boy
look just like me I just want to get him
you know protect him teach him yeah yeah
it's mine um oh now you know I got
cheated a lot table our family cheated
me
didn't give me that chance when I really
needed it he took from me and it hurt so
I turned to the neighborhood the homies
my next step is just keep helping people
helping the more I help I'm not a
Christian I'm spiritual
I help people I believe in helping and I
give you got to know when to give you
got to know not win the give you gotta
know when to be kind-hearted and
cold-hearted because people play games
and like I say I learned it's like
wisdom and uh I just a helper man that's
how I survive I help a lot of people I
give you a hand if you need something I
get my pay like Jesus you know he'd have
no paycheck or no uh no time pocket but
uh a time clock yeah and he probably had
no paycheck he just worked for trade for
labor and all that so I still I carried
myself like that I'll give everybody a
hand but I'm I'm a heat I'm gonna
survive I don't care about all the other
stuff you know I used to but nah it's
not important you leave yourself open he
hurt killed you know it's too much going
on and they plagued this whole
everything everything is messed up this
is all I got left
that little bit yeah see I was a slow
learner to my special education I
couldn't focus didn't teacher I couldn't
I guess I was a development
I'm looking at the glamour looking at
I'm not listening
so I'm failing they put me in a
different class so we're all the same
and uh now I learned how to learn that's
like I owed I'm a slow learner I learned
how to listen and pay attention and
that's how I learned how to do roofing
electrician election X electrical stuff
like a telephone poles I helped out but
they teach me and I'm so focused now but
you have to get it all the bad
influences out of are you clear you're
clear your mind keep that that bullcrap
that better keep it out of your temple
it's like you're putting bad food in
you're gonna start looking bad you're
gonna start feeling bad God put the good
in you know it's like we're temples you
know it's we're all family but you gotta
love yourself got a care stay off the
liquor store stay off the weed
dispensary whatever they call it don't
smoke it Oh people going crazy out there
you know
they own that other stuff they chemicals
man it's a mess it's a mess but like I
say I ain't drinking nothing I never
drink to my life maybe okay we're
working on some bicycles and my homeboys
are drinking some beers past it I'm
buzzed next day come over we're working
on the bikes and hmm then that third or
fourth day the fourth day didn't show up
so I went to the store then I went to
distort and I start that third day okay
no business going Steph little market I
liquor store down here dad that beer
could stay up fridge over here and I
because I felt an addiction coming I
felt that craving and that's what I'm
afraid of
spot being strong now I'm sad cuz you
don't know what may happen you got to be
able to take care of yourself and take
care of others and help
I tell there you pull your pants up
don't get that tattoo don't get in that
gang today they don't care about you
you're not telling the dangers no I try
to my God gave me the second chance to
reach out its outreach to see people out
there falling don't don't help them kill
their self help them survive we're all
related y'all even me and you related
yeah I'd be out here just like they do I
don't mess with nobody I stay to myself
they already know you come that's with
me I'll be right there
I'm gonna talk to you leave me alone I
just leave now you catch me on my way
out
you got a good one a fairly good I don't
need no help neither Sam talk to you get
up
that's some well food I'm a good guy all
right